the metaphor of painting made me think
of a painting that's only partially
finished and how we have to imagine the
rest of it that was the case with this
story wasn't it part of it was real but
the rest of it you had to bring to the
screen yourself it was about piecing
together the history that we had and and
that meant a lot of digging and a lot of
research a heck of a lot of research but
we also involved descendants of Lord
Mansfield every generation they
designate one member of the family to be
the custodian of the family history and
this generation it's a young man called
William Stormont who will be the is the
future Lord Mansfield and so he came on
board also as our consultant so that we
were able to see the real portraits of
what these characters in the movie look
like you know the uniform that captains
- John Lindsey wore real sort of
pamphlets we recreate the pamphlets and
the kind of news stories of the day but
actually looking at real pamphlets of
the time and it was yeah absolutely it
was about creating the fictional
elements that would support the history
rather than making any kind of mockery
of it or kind of undermining the history
did the family police you not really
they were fine they were just thrilled
that we could you know make this film
and focus on this extraordinary family
member of theirs and and you know back
in the day also showing a light on what
time Lord Mansfield himself did so
they'd be fully supportive and and you
know now taking advantage of the fact
the English heritage where they're
they're a family home in Scoon Perth and
also Kenwood house and are able to sort
of you know wouldn't have that junkets
there and hopefully the interest in that
in the portrait will I mean many
visitors will come I think you think
it's just also fair to say between the
what a mediator boat Lee was you know to
find the story because the painting
obviously the portrait is the two
sisters so and once upon a time there
were various versions of this
of drafts and of our film where it was
which story we took was it gonna be the
love story was he gonna be die die so it
was gonna be the two sisters or even a
thriller a legal thriller honorable John
Grisham yeah all of the above kind of it
was I mean I think the other thing about
the Mansfield family is that they are
rightfully very proud of this history
I'm really very proud of taking care of
the painting the real painting is
luminous and beautiful and incredible
but they're very proud of this history
and so I think they were glad and I
think they knew right from the get-go
this was going to be a positive story I
wanted to tell a positive story about
because whilst this is a obviously a
sweeping love story it's that the
romantic love story between John and
Dido it's also a paternal love story
between father and daughter and I think
that they knew all along that we wanted
to do something very you know positive
this is a good part of our history so
they were fine what who had the Epiphany
how many people walk by this painting
and say how very interesting and nothing
happens something happened to make this
film well I'm sticking to the story that
it was Damian's wife tell us Damian my
introduction to it was indeed from my
better half there were I was also
alerted to it by the actress Naomi
Harris and indeed the writer Julian
Fellowes and while I was looking for a
writer for it came across missense a guy
who had also come across the painting
was had been doing a project on on Lord
Mansfield himself so we teamed up and
then that's how at the genesis of it all
and in fact originally we couldn't you
know slightly ironically given you know
the subject matter we couldn't find a
home for it in the UK originally it was
HBO who developed it with us and then I
brought it back to the UK with times are
changing people had you know were
interested and then amer and I am with
the BFI you know over time I need to
take you to a place where you know
hopefully everyone can see the the power
of that portrait well I felt a great
deal of responsibility but
responsibilities can also hamper
creativity and so but but
what it did do rather than the family
policing me it policed me so that again
as I say the any fictional elements that
were created were created in order to
support the history and so as an example
I'll give you an example of that um John
is not a lawyer it was was not a lawyer
in real life he was a valet in the
Mansfield household so he did work in
the Mansfield household but he wasn't a
lawyer
two things I needed him to be a lawyer
so that I could explore the legal
question when it came to the zone I
could explore both sides of that legal
question but also John's story is
actually Lord Mansfield story as a young
man so Lord Mansfield born in in
Scotland to a wonderful family at some
point a political opposition comes into
power and finds heavily finds the family
the family becomes property rich but
cash poor so at 14 years old he sent
over two from Scotland to England to
make his fortune from nothing net he has
name but nothing else he is taken under
the wing of a couple of lawyers who find
him to be a great orator and educate him
in the law he's passionate he's he's you
know his his moral gauge is kind of you
know where it should be and but he he
doesn't have the money to educate
himself and so I wanted John to reflect
who Lord Mansfield was as a young man
and and also to tell Lord Lord Mansfield
story without necessarily having to see
Lord Mansfield as a young man so it was
about taking those elements of history
and then kind of imprinting them in a
way or projecting them in a way that
again would would would into fiction in
a way that would support the history so
that's the kind of thing that really
that I tried to do the portrait itself
whose title is bell and vet a hundred
years later was actually just called bet
as in Elizabeth the white girl and the
family over time had sort of you know
for a few decades rubbed her out of the
family history and she was only said if
I may say reinstated as the
correct title of the portrait I think in
the 1950s so so it's all it's more
complex
meperidine united states the one-drop
rule versus the blueblood ruled yes the
color of the blood there seemed to trump
which is a very unusual cultural impact
well yeah I mean but then I think that
that was the choice that the man made
not the choice that society would have
made because I think that you know by
Lord Mansfield choosing to define Dido's
value via her father's race as opposed
to via her mother's race I think that
was a very personal choice I'm not 100%
certain that that would have been there
the sort of that would have been
society's choice necessarily and that is
why in formal situations she couldn't
join the family because there was a
sense of well we can break the rules as
much as we like but we cannot break them
on behalf of other people we can't
expect to to put you know other people
to break the rules if they don't want to
but then when Bette confronts her and
they're both so angry the word that
comes out of Beth's mouth I was
expecting Negro and she said
illegitimate and I wanted to take you
there because I'm for me what this was
about but you know I wanted this this
movie to be about female the female bond
sistership sisterhood and so what I
wanted to do was put as much pressure on
the relationship as possible so that you
could see how tight the bond is and I
wanted you to love both the girls
however if I had taken Elizabeth there
with that line you never would have come
back from that you you know she would
have been lost to us you never would
have liked that girl from that moment
what she did was she took the she took
the easier Road so I was not allowed to
to be at the table for both reasons
because she's illegitimate and black and
yes spoken in one unspoken yes and
therefore that is the word that was
going to come out of her mouth but she
was she you know at the at the last
moment she can't go there she's never
done it before as a child she makes the
choice to love died I mean there have
been various versions of this story and
certainly before I came on board and
Damian's version that he talks about
with that was at HBO that didn't work
out but even prior
- today Mian trying to tell this story
there are short films there have been
plays on in the UK and they tend to
portray the relationship between
Elizabeth and and Dido as one of
conflict one where the two girls don't
like each other when I looked at the
painting that's not what I saw III saw
love between the two girls and so I
wanted to whilst giving you drama you
know Express that love